it's very easy to get wrapped up in
these songs and be like wow this is so
sad and it is sad i mean it's
it's sad i've been really sad when i get
there
promise you'll track me down
and show me around but it's so
exciting to be on the other side of it
and to show people
look at me i just did all of this in the
public eye right in front of you and
chose to let you in on it and chose to
show you that it wasn't great
but look at me now and i'm coming to you
from a place of going i've been there
too and i understand your struggle
you sold me on the fantasy
damn it all feel real to me
this album you know it stems from
challenging times in your life like you
said losing your very close friend the
end of a marriage
what did you learn about yourself during
this time how strong i am
and how music continues to save me
i dug deeper than i ever have into
my heart and wanted to
just really be even more honest than i
ever thought i could be
and just continually said to myself if i
could
help one person dealing with something
make
it seem like they're going to be okay
then it's worth it i love this about the
press release
when it comes to this album it said
seven songs that captured truth
about life so what are some of the
truths that you've learned and now
live by that you're stronger than you
think um
that your circumstances don't have to
define you they can refine you
that sometimes life gets messy and it's
okay to not be okay
and that god works all things together
for good